that is really a tough act to follow and
as an editor I don't get to follow many
acts like that six years ago the first
time I attended an Academy board meeting
has a new governor i sat at this huge
conference table in the boardroom up at
the seventh floor of the Academy seemed
like something out of dr. Strangelove
but they're sitting across from me was
and the coats where are you an and I was
real I realized that I was sitting with
editorial royalty after subsequent
meetings I would occasionally give an a
lift home to her apartment on the top of
la cienega and and always had a
wonderful matter of fact perspective on
the evenings topics and discussions to
help me see them more clearly it didn't
take me long to start to get the sense
of what Ann's process must be like in
the cutting room a concise approach that
ultimately made a scene resonate with
clarity emotion and serve the best
interests of the story we also did a
little gossiping about other editors
maybe a few directors which along with
which was discussed at the board
meetings I am not at liberty to disclose
with you tonight you want to meet me
afterwards I'll be glad to tell you but
Ann's greatest joy came from talking
about her family her children and her
grandchildren and accomplishments are
unparalleled and their groundbreaking on
so many levels okay out of sight okay
you remember the dialogue scene with
George Clooney and Jennifer Lopez and
all of a sudden and froze the image
it was so unexpected and so effective at
it enhanced the chemistry on the screen
between the two stars so on a recent
project I said you know what why not
steal from the best of them i'm going to
try the hand coats freeze frame and this
is with denzel washington and Paula
Patton okay and it didn't work at all it
just looked like another one of my
frequent mistakes which editor which
directors are very free to tell me about
so and if you need a ride home after the
ceremony tonight and you can tell me a
little bit about your process and maybe
divulge a few other secrets with me I'm
I'm all ears so on behalf of my fellow
governors my fellow extraordinary
governors from the film and urges branch
Carol littleton and Marco Blatt and
every editor every editor in our branch
it is my honor and privilege to
congratulate you we are also proud that
you have been recognized by the Board of
Governors I am proud to be a part of
that August group that we bestow this
richly deserved honor congratulations
and all my love and admiration you've
brought great joy to my life and it's a
privilege for me to be here Thank You
Anne